c'est aujourd'hui que jocelyne trottier
72 ans reçoit son panier alimentaire
ça tombe bien elle avait besoin de
réconfort moral
papa orient avec la pluie qui tombait
confinées chez elles depuis un mois
madame trottier n'a plus à s'inquiéter
pour la nourriture
c'est un constat de moins ça me soulage
énormément cas qui m'ont annoncé soeur
de venus m'aider
l'initiative est née ici au bouc
humanitaire nous amener de raffarin
avant leur vote à nouveau un organisme
dirigé par une habituée de l'aide
internationale qui a sillonné les
endroits les plus sinistrées de la
planète et qui ne pouvait pas rester les
bras croisés devant cette crise on a
carrément pris le bottin le cap en un
point d'indicé on va appeler tout le
monde parce que on a des nouveaux
démunis on a des gens qui normalement ne
sont pas sur les listes entre hyde
donc on a appelé dans tous les foyers
qu'on a pu et on a dit comment savent
aujourd'hui
et de là on a trouvé beaucoup beaucoup
de cas d'urgence les gens qui étaient
laissés à eux mêmes
lebouc manta bonjour le téléphone
n'arrête pas de sonner
au bout du fil des gens réclament de
l'aide augmente à bonjour des citoyens
offrait la leur l'estac arrive un peu de
partout le matin c'est que c'est un peu
des petits miracles qu'on voit arriver à
longueur de journée
l'organisme a des allures de ruche
d'abeilles en pleine production
aujourd'hui c'est 25 30 livraison plus
tout qu'est-ce qui vous a ajouté sera
ajouté
l'aide provient des banques alimentaires
des commerçantes mais aussi de
particuliers
on peut tous faire une action qui fait
divers va la vie de quelqu'un en ce
moment une fois n'est pas ni près les
bénévoles prennent la route du pont
infirmières chevaux médecin et je peux
pas être aux premières loges pour aller
vraiment aidé mais ça on est capable de
venir donner un sourire puis un petit un
petit orgue virtuel de quoi redonner le
sourire à madame trottier beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour et de câlins quelqu'un
ce sera ta virtuel je les bras ici à
sucre hayat radio canada montréal